alright thanks band for inviting me and
all the other organizers I think it's
great to be in an audience of experts
like this so with a lot of feedback so
my talk is about copy number changes and
often you know because of the
complexities of handling CNVs people
talk more about deletions and so on but
I'm really want to focus on
amplifications and I think if you look
at cancel it's been known for a long
time and that's why I'm showing somewhat
older data this is a hybridization data
which show all of these patterns of
large regions of the genome being
amplified and I think a good question to
ask is what is it what's the mechanism
behind these kinds of amplifications you
know oftentimes you think about tandem
duplications and other basic models of
rearrangement which can amplify but
those are usually not sufficient to
address these kinds of dramatic changes
over somewhat tight break points right
so so over the last few years people
have been developing different models
and I'll sort of pick three of them and
talk about each of them in some levels
of details of the the first is the
somewhat exotic model of breakage fusion
bridge which when they first started
sequencing paired-end reads and so on so
back in 2007 bignell littell had this
very nice paper where they said that
look this amplification actually bears
all of the hallmarks of the breakage
fusion bridge model which was first
proposed by Barbara McClintock back back
in 1941 so something very ancient now
playing a role in cancer and it's good
to see if we can find similar patterns
in cancer so the other model that I'll
talk about is this model and of course
this has led to many other similar
models that I'll just talk about croma
trips asst which really is when you
think about it quite an extraordinary
event first proposed by Stephenson 2011
where they said that in this model the
genome just shatters into many pieces
and then the pieces come together and
that's why you get these interesting all
alternating copy number pattern changes
as
less very complex rearrangements and the
question is can we detect more of these
in the tumor genomes and then we go back
to something that's really ancient
compared to these models or so-called
episome model of amplification which
actually has been studied a lot by
cytogenetic people and then there were
some early work done by Rafael in person
there many years ago but it hasn't
really got the interest of the people in
the sequence analysis committee in
community and I think we should really
think about that too and the model has
many parts and I'll go over these
because I'm not going to talk a lot
about this model in this talk but but I
will come back to it towards the very
end so in this model fragments break off
at random the form extra chromosomal
elements and and through recombination
events and as well as sometimes they
carry these origins of replication they
can replicate and so they can make more
copies and again this is random but the
key thing here is that they don't have
the centromere and because they don't
have centromere when the cells divide
their sort of random segregation and one
cell might have more or less copies and
if a cell carries some kind of an
oncogene or something that has
proliferative properties maybe that cell
has selective advantage if it has more
copies and the number of copies per leaf
proliferate and that sort certainly is
as a way of explaining hi counts of
amplification in the tumor genome so the
kinds of questions that you might ask is
well if you have your tumor genome
sample which of these mechanisms is
going to be okay so again we have some
input data mostly in the form of
sequence data because that's the most
common one and you would like to assign
some kind of mechanism to the
amplifications that you are seeing and
we are a long way towards answering this
question systematically but I will take
some examples to show how it can work in
specific instances and i'll start with
breakage fusion bridge because in some
ways it's it's about the most cleanest
the descriptions the most clean so so
just you know an obligatory picture of
Barbara McClintock back in 1939 where
she
first talked about this phenomenon
digitally arises when you have a break
at the telomere and that causes
instability of the genome so during
anaphase when the sister chromatids are
formed there's a bridge that's formed to
stabilize the the broken ends and that
causes a problem when these cells are
separating right so just sort of this
animation will explain the picture so
here we have two chromosomes which are
stuck together by this bridge and now we
have dysentery chromosomes and when the
cell division they'll be stress on these
chromosomes so they have to break again
right and just to show you some original
data this is from a breast carcinoma
sample and you can see there's a probe
showing where the centromeres are and
you see all of these chromosomes with
two probes lighting up showing dysentery
chromosomes so it's sort of breakage
fusion bridge in action right and when
when these chromosomes I mean the
centromeres move apart they will break
but they don't have to break necessarily
at the bridge and so what that results
in is that if you segment this
chromosome then you get a prefix portion
duplicate it and invert it and this
process now that the you know this end
is broken again this process can go on
for a few cycles until either the bridge
is formed or a Patersons right so so
just in a few cycles you end up getting
a highly rearranged genome and again and
then you can see now this genome has
many many copies and an interesting
question that I sometimes give as
homework as if you are given a string
like this over letters with duplications
can you say if it can be created just
using breakage fusion bridge circles and
that's that's an easy question to solve
right but let's talk about what we would
get if he had sequence data so imagine
that you have your sampling from a
chromosome like this but these these
segments are very long like many tens of
kilo bases so even the long green
technologies today cannot bridge them
and it's very unlikely that you could
assemble and get the final structure so
what you could do is do
some kind of short reach sequencing or
other kind of sampling and then just get
copy number counts and so in this case a
comes with copy number 4 becomes with
copy number 4 and so on so the question
sort of very clean combinatorial
question is simply this that if you are
given copy number data such as this or
this is it consistent with a breakage
fusions can you start with ABCDE the
natural segmentation and through a
sequence of breakage fusion bridge
cycles can you get it all right so this
is the clean version and then of course
you have to add noise and be able to
resolve this and just to say that this
is an interesting community oriole
problem you can see that these two
counts are very similar and here I've
reduced the count of a by one and this
one does admit a bfp valles this one
doesn't and actually you can show that
all the even numbers must follow before
odd numbers maybe some of you can figure
that out while it so I'm not actually
the we have a linear time algorithm for
this but it's it's way too complex to be
explained I'm going to start with
somewhat and an earlier description
approach that we had to the problem
because it's just it gives some more
insight into the structure and then I'll
give you some hints about how the actual
algorithm proceeds alright so here the
slide is not empty I have put the string
right out here and let's just do a few
cycles on it but this time what we are
going to do is as the amplification
happens we will put the is always on the
a's the bees always on the bees and c is
always on the season that that will
allow for the structure to reveal itself
alright so the first case we had this a
be prefix inverted and duplicate it and
you get a structure like this then you
have another one another one and then at
the very end you can take the entire
string and duplicate it and often if the
data is given to you like this you could
still do that extra simply by doubling
everything and that should be fine and
so you can see now that all the A's are
lined up the bees are lined up and you
can see a little bit more structure on
the breakage fusion which cyclin really
just to reiterate you know the problem
is given to you as a bunch of numbers in
this case 12 10 and 2 and the goal is to
be able to construct a sigh a path like
this which satisfies the breakage fusion
rich
alright so if you think about just sort
of joining out here you can see a
natural hierarchical structure and we
will exploit that so I join all the
adjacent is the adjacent bees in the
adjacencies and just make a tree so the
root node is still one corresponding to
the sea out here and then you have five
bees out here just half of the number of
bees because we are pairing up and and
then six or so is I can count on to be a
68 right so there's a tree and this tree
has very nice properties which we can
exploit first it is symmetric so if you
take any portion of the tree and you
rotate it you'll get an identical
structure and there's also something
that we call paired symmetry so if you
take any two consecutive occurrences of
the node and do sort of an inorder and
take the subtree that's inside that
that's also symmetric and then finally
the ends must be longer than the insides
at all subtree so if you have all of
these three properties it actually is a
breakage fusion bridge and then there's
a one-to-one connection because anytime
you have a tree like this you can do an
in order traversal and that will give
you a breakage fusion bridge so our
problem can be remodeled as saying
you're given these counts and can you
make trees which have this property
right and there isn't a poly know this
formulation actually doesn't work to get
an efficient algorithm but it takes you
part of the way and you just sort of
it's in enumerative algorithm so you
start at the top level there's only one
node and at the second level there are
these five nodes so there's only one way
to connect them and we just connect them
here but now we use the symmetry
property so whatever is the sub tree out
here is going to be the same as the sub
tree out here and whatever the sub tree
out here is going to be the same here so
we can represent that by multiplicities
and then we just solve sort of equations
that can construct possible pairings are
out here possible assignments of
children through these solutions of
these day event in equations and you
know if you keep going like this you
will get possible structure then you
have to sort of enumerate but the reason
it works is that every time we are
doubling the multiplicity and very soon
you know
up in a small number of steps the
multiplicities will be so high that they
are very few possibilities left so it
terminates in practice it does terminate
quickly for many examples so just some
example it's something that took you
know 20,000 seconds now takes 12 seconds
and by both are tractable numbers if you
want to do large-scale simulations the
second one is a big advantage you can do
really simulations with this and so we
you tried this we tried many many
different things and it works fine the
only problem is that if you have errors
you know if you allow sort of edit
distances from true pound vectors and
find the nearest bfb then these methods
just don't work in fact they can't
really distinguish except in some cases
they can say like in this case that the
nearest count vfb vector is so far away
that this is not an expect expression of
a beer be so it's a non-trivial problem
you're given counts like this in the
algorithm can say that it's bfp or not
so we had to work harder to actually get
the positive result and I'm just going
to go in couple of slides to give you a
sense of how that thing works so here we
have the same palindrome but it has sort
of been laid on its side and this time
we go layer by layer and sort of just
going through a couple of layers over
here we have these blocks and you want
to wrap the bees so all the bees are on
this layer and but because there are
fewer sees then then bees we just have
to add some extra empty strings and we
can wrap them so in one case it's very
easy but in another case where you have
these nine blocks and they have to be
folded into seven blocks you have to do
it in a very complex way and that's what
that's what makes the algorithm really
hard so here we combine two of these two
of these and the nine now become five
blocks and then we add two extra empty
strings to get the seven and that's how
we can wrap so there's a collection of
wrapping and folding in the way it works
as we define kind of potential function
and if you really optimize the potential
function in every step if there is a bfp
it will turn
in linear time so it works very fast in
principle and now that really gives us a
handle to talk about BF be alright so
just some quick results on this before
we move on so if you start with you know
BFBS of length 6 you can see that you
have and this is sort of simulated data
where we had about many sort of normal
rearrangements and in the case of BF be
the true positive examples we still had
those normal rearrangements and we also
embedded some vfb cycles in them so if
you take see a BF piece of length 6 it's
the situation's hopeless but as you get
longer and longer BF piece using the
more advanced algorithm you can start
getting better results results like this
so if you're not quite there but then we
use one other trick that you can get
from sequencing which is that when you
have a minus a you know duplications of
this form they lead to these fold back
kinds of parents mappings and an excess
of fold back is also a clue to bfp so we
just sort of combine the distance from
the nearest bfp with the count vector
and and this excess of hold back and
that allows us to get results that are
much better so we can get up to eighty
percent true positive in the simulations
with small so the challenge here is
though that there aren't many we tried
this on a whole bunch of TCGA data we
only have a handful of examples maybe
three or four examples where we can
conclusively say that bfp has happened
it does say that if there are a few bfp
cycles you cannot really distinguish if
you have ten or twelve bfp cycles you
can actually do it so here's one example
that campbell showed and our algorithm
picks it out here's another that we find
which is very similar in properties and
you can see the sort of counts and then
we have a few other examples like this
all right so the conclusion is that this
problem while it has valid admits a good
algorithmic solution and and you know it
probably can be improved but we already
have a good handle on it is probably a
rare event it's not the thing that
explains a bulk of amplifications so
let's talk about cropper trip system let
me see
so this model is actually turns out to
be more interesting and in a sort of i
would say in a in a sort of negative
fashion because this one the hypothesis
is truly extraordinary it says that tens
to hundreds of genomic rearrangements
happen in a one of cellular crisis this
sort of shatter and then come back
together and it happens in a single
event and this has to be opposed against
a sort of null hypothesis which is just
that as progression of rearrangement
events happen and that's what's causing
these amplifications and when you think
about these two it's the timing that's
the critical part and that's what makes
it very tricky to handle in an
algorithmic fashion so when when Stevens
proposed this they also came up with a
nice sort of Monte Carlo based
simulation idea and it's worth looking
into what they try so here you have some
kind of rearrangements is to explain
that that there's this particular
notation about how to display
breakpoints of different types and so as
you accumulate rearrangements you will
also your genome is going to get more
and more rearrangement and what they
showed in their simulation is that if
you start from a normal genome and then
you start simulating rearrangement so
here you have sorry this is too small to
read but this is a duplication and
inversion another tandem duplication and
so on as you accumulate these
rearrangements you indeed get an
increase in the sort of discordant pair
edge signals but you also get an
increase in the number of copy number
state so when you look at the picture of
copy numbers you'll get many many
different possible counts many copy
number state so what they say is that if
you do only progressively arrangements
yes you will get a lot of rearrangements
but you'll also get a lot of copy number
states and so they did the simulation
where this is what progressive
rearrangements we give you you as you
increase the number of breakpoints or
the number of deserve discordant reads
you also get enlarge increase in the
number of copy number States and what
they say is that well if you lie outside
of this distribution patch chroma trips
asst okay that was their functional
definition of chroma trips and they
I did on a bunch of examples and came up
with these three now there are many
issues with this kind of any sort of
have to poke holes not to say that
chroma trip says doesn't exist but if
you're going to try and find it
algorithmically you have to be a little
bit more cautious alright so the first
thing is we did find some errors in
their codon they actually recognized
that later in a subsequent paper and
that already bends this curve a little
bit then the other things are just sort
of obvious that if you take the you know
a loser definition of break points and
so on then again the curve still begin
you know begins to bend more and more
towards these examples and we took
things that were common in microarray
relative to what how confidently you
could call the breakpoints and also
impaired and sequencing so these are
minor things but then we realize one
thing that when we did these simulations
it a big difference comes from what kind
of rearrangements you choose so if you
limit yourself to deletions for example
this is sort of an extreme in a stupid
example but it illustrates the point and
inversions inversions don't change puppy
number whereas the deletions only reduce
the copy number by one so if you did one
large deletion and then you did a bunch
of inversions you're going to end up
with exactly to copy number States and a
complex rearranged you know much like
the chroma Texas pattern that they came
up with right so so if you give this to
their code if you give this as the input
it does show up as showing up right in
outside of this their main curve and it
would be selected as an example of
chroma trips asst all right so finally
we did it the other way round also we
used sort of the rearrangement theory
with you know breakpoint graphs and
minimum rearrangement distance and we
just showed that look at you take one of
their examples this is the example to
the far right and you try to mimic a to
a series of progressive rearrangements
you get sort of all of these
rearrangements but you mainly use
inversions and deletions so as to
minimize the number of copy number
states and if you did that in a sort of
clever fashion you can actually get it
sorry I there is a movie out here
let's see if it works here yes we did it
was so we we made a you may already have
the target graph so we sort of know
which things must come which must be
rearranged so and then there are things
that are just missing from the data
which have which you know because the
original data had copy number states
which were low and high and so you can
just sort of delete that portion it's
sort of a greedy procedure plus plus
some break point so we can talk offline
I can tell you how we did it
unfortunately the movie isn't quite
working but you can see out here that we
can match most of the break points there
are a few extra break points that we
create and a few that we don't have and
we still maintain the copy number States
all right so I mean this was a
tongue-in-cheek paper we actually had a
lot of trouble getting it published a
lot of rejections including from my coma
trips as community not surprisingly so I
want to sort of summarize the criticism
that we got some of it is actually quite
reasonable so you know it's not we are
not claiming that what we have is an
alternative model but just what it is so
first first was that you only use
inversions and deletions that's
completely unrealistic and it's true our
goal wasn't to say that that's what it
is but just that if you're coming out
with the computational signature you
have to be careful about what kind of
assumptions you make so definite
definitely that's true and then I also
want to point out that Pellman and
others have come up with really
beautiful experiments there's a paper
from a couple of years ago where they
sort of show that if you can induce in a
way they can induce a chromosome to lag
behind during cell division and that
lagging chromosome actually does shatter
so they can show sort of parts of chroma
trips is in action and clearly some
phenomenon is happening and so you
cannot sort of say that chroma trips is
itself doesn't occur that it's just that
it might be a little bit trickier to
find all right and so finally you know a
very nice idea from the Rafael group
made this very nice point that the whole
debate between what we are saying and
what sort of the chroma trips this group
is saying is simply this that
when you have progressive rearrangements
if you don't allow break points to be
reused then you'll automatically get an
increase in copy number of states if you
allow break points to be reused and
using the same break points again then
automatically through inversions you can
create the break points but you can keep
a check on the number of copy number
states so so the question really is this
that if you want to distinguish between
chroma trips asst and you want to
distinguish between sort of something
that's happening progressive on a
one-off basis maybe the timing is the
most important thing maybe this is the
example that you can use to to do that
but then I can tell you that there are
many other equally likely models which
would provide similar signature and so I
want to spend the last two slides just
talking about sort of the old model of
episome construction right so in this
model you have these little pieces that
break off and and then you know come out
and they form these episodes and as I
said if these contain origins of
replication they will form many copies
and they can proliferate right so so
here's sort of a cartoon of this but I
want to before I show that want to show
you some data that is actually that
people who are sort of in the sequence
community have you know it's what
looking back at some of these data sets
and seeing what's happening the point
here is that these extra chromosomal
fragments and a double minut formations
are not something that is a rarity there
are many many cancer samples where if
you just looked under a microscope you
would see lots and lots of copies of
this and this is sort of an example
where you see 20 double my new it's
occurring in this region okay so this is
something that's not you know not
something that's rare if you had
something like this where these
fragments were breaking off and so you
have these fragments coming together or
min episome and then this episode or the
double mine you you know depending on
the size forms many copies when you look
at its signature on the genome you're
going to get an increase in copy number
States but they will all be the same
number of copies so you will get these
oscillating copy number pattern
you will get the rearrangements right so
again now this is these events have
happened progressively the pieces didn't
how all break off at the same time but
because of the eventual proliferation
they could lend up with the signature
like chroma crypsis right it's at least
i'm not i'm not giving you proof here
we'd actually we are working on some of
these problems but i don't have all of
the data yet but sort of just to say
that there's a big continuum of
mechanisms which can be used to explain
different phenomena alright so then you
might go and say well these are extra
chromosomal structures you know they
don't talk up they don't say anything
about rearrangements that happen on the
chromosome where we really think about
you know the rearrangement community
operations like double cut and join or
genome rearrangements or breakage fusion
bridge and all of these other things so
even that part is now sort of falling
apart there's a very nice paper it's
done by our collaborators and it's from
a two years back where they showed this
really i think it was quite a quite a
fascinating results so you have this
example of egfr amplification and you
can see all of the double mind you it's
lighting up in red because the probe was
on the on the mutant form of egfr so
it's a glioblastoma sample and when you
give drug to it you know this it's known
to confer resistance but when you
actually give the drug and you look at
this cells you can see that all of these
double my newts have disappeared and
they've integrated into this chromosomal
region forming what's called in HSR NHS
are just stands for homogeneously
staining regions which means that you
know things under they don't show the
classic banding patterns but for us it's
the same thing as saying that the double
minut integrated back into the
chromosome and then when you remove the
drug and so the resistances you know
there's no longer that selective
pressure the double mine you to come
back so it's a thing that can go back
and forth and it tells us and they're
not the only ones who pointed this out
that these double my nudes can go in and
come out and my student vadaj who's in
the audience has done a lot of work on
the sort of sequence analysis of this I
don't have the time to talk about the
algorithms and all that he used by
he basically did a structural analyses
of these and here I'm not showing the
break points for simplicity just sort of
the copy number patterns and so these
are replicate samples from the naive
case this is the sample from the drug
resistance case where it here's the
episome of the DM integrated back into
the episome and came back out after the
drug was removed and you can see that
yes there are changes but the fine but
the structure is broadly recapitulated
it's the same same sort of rearranged
structure that's going into the
chromosome and coming back out so when
you see rearranged a part of the
chromosome it could well be the result
of a DM integrating into the chromosome
all right so we're doing some more work
on this but I want to just sort of lay
out this somewhat more controversial
idea that maybe it could be that this
sort of older episome based model of
chromosomal replication is is one of the
dominant mechanisms by which these
amplifications can happen in can
survivors the other methods like
breakage fusion bridge and chroma trip
cesare probably oddities which do happen
but not not with that high frequency and
then these you know if you understand
this then they can help us give a better
handle on focal amplifications in cancer
and of course I think continuing to
distinguish between these models and
actually say for a sample what exactly
sampling is going to be an interesting
research area going forward all right so
I want to thank Sheikh if he did the
hard algorithm for BF e that I didn't
talk about and Marcus Kinsella who did a
lot of the bfb and chroma trips aswer
that I did talk about and then garage
has been working quite hard on episode
reconstruction and hope to speak to you
about that in the near future and I also
want to thank our collaborators Paul
Michelle and Frank ordinary with whom we
are exploring this episode based months
thank you
sorry was very confusion fridge practice
two other can you tell what the order of
the events are or can you say how many
different evolutions gave the site
brightly tribution bridge back to Chris
asked a very nice question not
surprising coming from him he said when
you have a the breakage vision bridge
the way we say that it's breakage fusion
is bridges that we can actually give a
sequence of BFB cycles which which you
know which implies some kind of an order
but and he's asking if you can actually
tell what the order is so not in our our
models don't discriminate you know there
are many many are generally when
something follows BF be there many
orders that are compatible with it but
of course there's been a lot of work
done and I think Chris has done some
work to vary if you look at mutations
and you can sort of you know see how the
mutations are the somatically acquired
mutations on these how they fall you can
give some timing based on that and so
it's sort of more detailed work which we
kind of understand and there are others
who have done it but we haven't done it
ourselves so we just say whether or not
this be when you mention bright boy
breeze as well as wondering if you
assume breakpoint reuse for the break
confusion rich stuff yeah because we at
that level you know we are talking about
many sort of tens of KBS to hundreds of
kb long segments and we really talking
about sort of gross changes in copy
numbers so so we assume sort of within
that you know we don't have the big
point doesn't have to be very accurate
now what are the pros and cons of that
if you have very accurate segmentation
with precise breakpoints you will get
finer counts but then you have to
remember that the true samples anyway
heterogeneous mix of many different
events not all of them have the same
amount of so they always this noise and
what we do is we really we don't answer
the question as a yes no question but we
say what's the smallest number of edits
you have to make
to make it compatible with something
that's breakage you and that's robust to
sort of changes in break finer break
points as well as some changes in copy
number and if that distance is small and
there's an excess of fold back
operations that's when our statistic
says that it is you know so we have a
combined status that it is BFE okay so
saw her and then maybe power and then
you just mentioned this issue chronology
of the sample actually use that to your
advantage that is if you had several
patterns that you know coexist so to
speak in the same sample that your
advantage to be able to determine the
process by which yes if we had you know
high quality sort of single-cell data
and so on we could do it if we just have
the mix then then it's a bit harder
multiple small sample multiple small
samples all of which have the same
operation possibly I don't have you know
what you're saying is definitely
possible but we don't have the data the
two engines is it time already to start
sequencing this region Lindsay baby
model these longer it technologies
you'll see reason so these are the
segments are much longer than what the
longer it technologies will give us they
are they are they are anywhere from 50
to hundreds of kilo bases in many cases
when it's it of course depends from and
we only have a handful of cases where we
strongly believe that it is vfb but it's
always like 50 like 50 kb or something
and then many of these longer
technologies are actually unsuited for
high number of duplications even though
I mean Sarah famous in the audience you
can sort of contradict me but when you
are taking what if you with the bar
coding based technologies you're using
the proximity on the genome to say that
they come together so if you want to do
you know sort of if you have
duplications and the duplicated forms
are sort of inverted and so on it's not
yet clear how these what kind of signal
they will give on these these long range
maybe you want to say something so open
it was going to say something to a bug I
wonder how often you see the full-back
inversion can you expect them to be
there when we've looked at the data we
tend to see fewer full backs than we
would expect and there's some hypothesis
that it might be hard with alumina data
to actually see full backs if they
really are essentially a power drops and
if you read that the palindrome so
whether you think there's a detection
problem with full baths and short reads
it is so we don't see in general you
would see very few fold back reads and
so when you're talking about 12 segments
and you're talking about sort of just
you know in those 12 just seeing if at
each of those 12 positions you have an
excess of hold back the numbers are
quite small and even a small number will
be s yes yes oh yeah yeah after the
amplification yes yes we do so we only
treat presence and absence of a fullback
at a separate we don't actually use the
counts themselves but yeah you're right
we don't see a lot of those and I don't
have a good reason but it it could be it
could be a technology issue
that's true that is true but I think to
do sort of high coverage back by on
human would be you know just different
yeah but maybe it's the other yes so
this is amazing they are now about the
chromosome confirmations from I see a
GOP is there any support for this it's
possible I mean I've looked at a lot of
high C data and we've used it for
phasing genomes and so on it must be
experts yes so they can contradict me if
that's true or not as you get long you
know if you get more and more distant
connections with high see there's a
chance that you are connecting trance
chrome you know two different
chromosomes versus the same and you have
to kind of filter that out most of the
interesting pairs you get within 100 kb
and you know a lot of the structural
work that is done sort of more gross and
it talks about sort of local domains and
so on and then the follow-up work is
just saying all that these regions seem
to be proximal or something like that so
i'm not sure that the scales match up in
a way that we could use it for
complexity arrangements like this but if
somebody has better example din at least
in the data that we have looked at it
doesn't seem to be used oh yes yes also
show you oh you were saying something
about intrachromosomal so then i didn't
understand your question i mean you're
saying that most of the contacts are
within what they call paths but the work
area social the domain which are maybe a
few hundred kgs but still since you're
counting all the touching the point of
everything you know
collecting a lot of information also
about winter comes over yes what is
conceived to be in the chromosomal
because using the reference the moment
so it's possible that we can use it I
haven't I don't haven't used it I don't
have anything interesting yes in the
regressive model you might expect that
that some events would actually be dil
Dil terious himself and therefore not
observed so you leverage that too in
your models to potentially explain what
we do observe so so that early events
that are essentially fixed with
resultant very strong
I don't have any I mean it's a good
question I think the question that was
posed as that the progressive events if
they happen in sort of later they can be
if there are some deleted as events you
know there's also a selection that's
going on along with that I mean I get
your comment i just am i have maybe you
have to talk offline i don't quite
connect it with what i talked about but
maybe there's a way i mean if you sort
of if you look at the the talk that nico
gave in the morning and you see that
there's you know many of the times you
see like a big chain of events followed
by a branching it is because there's
some kind of selection at work whenever
you have selection you see a lineage
growing very strongly and then of course
towards the tail you still see a lot so
that's the kind of you see something
similar with rearrangements also but we
haven't done it we haven't ordered them
and we serve we don't know yet how best
to place the data but the but the idea
that you propose is definitely correct
here okay good